should we hit some golf balls game on
baby
I'm the most athletic man in the music
business
I ain't gonna lie y'all it's hard to
look this good and golf at the same time
[Music]
look at that puppy come on baby don't
play with me
can we talk about your new single killer
man oh dude which is all about your wife
it is you met her in Vegas yes oh she's
the best man
[Music]
I am over the moon with that woman she's
done ever I could I don't see any other
woman on Earth but her something about
you that love song is just one of 13
tracks on jelly rolls album Whitsett
Chapel which is out now this rising star
has quite a story The one-time troubled
teen who was in and out of jail for 12
years turned his life around through
music his inspiring journey is told in
his Hulu documentary jelly roll save me
in hopes the debut country album is
hopeful and therapeutic
[Music]
it's called I think at some point in
life everything in life has let me down
but music was always my consistent like
when I had nothing else I had a Boombox
when I was incarcerated I had a set of
headphones and a little radio when
someone else who has not let you down
Miss Bailey Anne your daughter has been
great inspiration to you so how did she
Inspire this album in your new music
well to say she hasn't let me down
[Music]
too right now and she let me down I'm
afraid she's gonna take a mailbox out
but uh she changed my life man knowing I
had her it was weird I never planned on
doing anything with my life but being a
criminal until that and jelly rolls got
the full support from this surprising
friendship The Rock right can you smell
with the Rockets
he's been my friend forever The Rock was
listening to Jelly Roll music when
Spotify numbers said only 30 000 people
were listening
he's really been with me from the
beginning he has a story that to me
music was there for him at a moment when
he needed it these Pinnacles in my
career he's always the first person in
my messages I'm thinking we need a
little collaboration right hey I told
him I'm getting I'm gonna lose some
weight get my active chops together baby
DJ I'm coming baby you know I got you
back baby I love you
[Applause]
[Music]